p comment tops gea
en politique privée vous n'êtes pas typique
scènes de raisin avec ce que serait le message
Bien cependant
des conseils ou un cheval vous pouvez lui procurer au plus vite
possible pour certains besoins physionomiques
bonjour
en pays j'appréciais le café
que vous pouvez facilement nos familles ou
quelqu'un dont tu as besoin appelé chimay
c'est une personne de projet pour mon bien
code magique
doudou tout simplement pour les enfants ainsi que la
aldéa
garder après quoi vous savez que le chirurgien le dit
alors tu prends ok bonnie dekker euros
joyeux anniversaire tu étais la Chine
argent sterling argent aussi tu aimes ça
visage mais j'entends tes premiers baisers
puis je me suis assis sur grand'o à temps puis assis
ce bébé
maman maman je t'ai assis et rita
[Musique]